Afraid of the answers to these
questions,
um,
can left and right wing people ever
meaningfully communicate with each
other.
And I'm wondering if you can comment a
little about temporary mentality and the
differences there in
that's what they do in a democracy.
Look,
the lefties,
they're high in openness and low in
conscientiousness and that means they
don't like responsibility that much,
but they're pretty damn creative and
they're not very orderly especially
they're not very orderly and that's part
of conscientiousness by the way.
And so they're good at being artists and
they're good at being entrepreneurs,
but they're terrible at running things.
But then the conservatives on the other
side,
they are low in openness,
which is the treat creativity.
That doesn't mean they're stupid by the
way.
It just means they're,
they're,
they're thinking isn't as free form,
let's put it that way.
And so it's more constrained and they're
high in conscientiousness,
especially orderliness.
So they're damn good at running things
that already work.
So you need the liberals.
There wouldn't be high openness,
low conscientiousness if there wasn't a
niche for it.
And you need the conservatives,
and sometimes the liberals are right,
the borders should be more open because
that's their fundamental claim,
and sometimes the conservatives are
right,
the borders between things should be
more closed and because they're both
right some of the time,
and because the environment keeps
snaking around,
you have to have dialogue between the
two sources constantly,
constantly so that the the polity can
orient itself as the snake of the
environment moves,
and that's why you need free speech.
And so the left and the right get along
perfectly well together as long as they
can talk to each other,
but as soon as they can't talk to each
other,
then the alternative,
there's only one altar to alternatives
to negotiation.
Simple as that.
One is slavery.
The other is tyranny.
So if those you cannot negotiate with
will either become your slaves or your
tyrants,
so you wipe outs free speech,
then that's what you're left with and
that's why free speech isn't just
another right,
for Christ's sake.
It's not just another.
Right?
How dumb can you be to think that you
don't know anything if you think that
it's the mechanism by which people have
different opinions talk instead of
strangling each other.
So and,
uh,
but if you want them to strangle each
other,
which you might then really,
you might then take away the right to
express their opinion and watched the
whole thing go up in flames and go like
this because maybe that's what a big
part of you want.